「実践で学ぶ量子コンピューティング」へようこそ。第6回だ。今日は私のお気に入りの
量子コンピュータの応用の一つ、自然のシミュレーションに焦点を当てる。このエピソードでは、
あらゆる種類の量子ダイナミクス問題に取り組むために必要なステップを解説する。量子ダイナミクス問題とは、
量子系の記述が時間とともにどう変化するかを求める問題だ。まず高レベルで説明し、具体的な例を取り上げて
詳しく見ていく。具体的には、量子ユーティリティを実証した2023年のIBMの実験だ。最初に簡単な動機づけとして、
量子コンピューティングの分野にいる私たちが何度も語り継ぐ、最も有名なエピソードの一つを紹介しよう。
それは、Richard Feynmanが1959年にCaltechで講演を行い、基本的に
その後数十年にわたって分野全体に動機を与えたという話だ。その講演は「There's Plenty of Room at the
Bottom」というユニークなタイトルで、基本的な主張は、微視的なレベルにはまだ
発見すべき豊かな物理学がたくさん残っているというものだった。
その特定の講演は、テクノロジーがかなり発展した80年代になるまであまり注目されなかった。そしてFeynmanは
時間をかけてメッセージを明確化・洗練させた。80年代にCaltechへ戻り、
「Simulating Nature with Computers」という別の論文を発表した。そこで彼が特に言及したのは、
コンピュータが自然とまったく同じことを行う正確なシミュレーションが存在する可能性だ。
本質的には、原子スケールで起きていることの粗い近似を排除し、それを
量子物理学を理解・活用するコンピュータに置き換えることで、自然がしていることをシミュレートするだけでなく、エミュレートできるということだ。
前のエピソードで示したこのタイムライングラフィックを思い出してほしい。一方の端には、簡単に
解ける問題があり、量子が提供できる速度向上を必要としない。しかし他方の端には、
非常に難しく、まだ持っていない耐障害性量子マシンを必要とする問題がある。
幸いなことに、現在取り組める中間の領域に多くのシミュレーション問題があると信じている。そして
この見通しに興奮・好奇心を覚える理由はたくさんある。なぜなら
自然のシミュレーションは、多くの刺激的なアプリケーション分野の基盤だからだ。いくつか挙げると、より良く
自然をシミュレートできれば、新材料の発見を加速し、より良い医薬品や医療を生み出し、あるいは
素粒子物理学や宇宙論の根底にある新しい物理学を探求できる。しかし私も含め誰もが
これらの刺激的な分野に量子コンピューティングを適用しようとする前に、
典型的なシミュレーションベースのワークフローの基本ステップを理解する必要がある。
まず、興味のある量子系を特定する。これにより、その時間発展を支配するHamiltonianと、
初期状態の意味のある記述がわかる。
次に、この状態の時間発展を実装するための適切な方法を見つける必要がある。これらの要素が
揃ったら、次のステップは実際の実験を実行することだ。
これには一般的に、時間発展アルゴリズムの量子circuit実装の最適化、
量子ハードウェア上でのcircuitまたは複数circuitの実行、そして結果のポストプロセッシングが含まれる。つまり、
シミュレーション実験の基本ステップを次のように名付けられる。
系のHamiltonianの特定、Hamiltonianエンコーディング、状態準備、状態発展、
circuit最適化、circuit実行、そしてポストプロセッシングだ。
しかしこれらはかなり詳細なステップだ。Qiskitパターンフレームワークの4つのステージを思い出してほしい。これは
Qiskitでルーティンを実装する方法を理解するためのもので、マッピング、circuit最適化、circuit実行、そして
ポストプロセッシングだ。つまりここの最初の4ステップはすべて実際にはマッピングという傘の下に含まれており、それが
この最初のステージに丸一回のエピソードを費やした理由だ。見逃した場合は前のエピソードに戻って見てほしい。
では、コーディングに入る前に、これらのステップが何を意味するかを一通り確認しよう。シミュレーション実験を行うために必要な
最初の基本的なことは、系を記述するHamiltonianを特定することだ。時には
よく知られている場合もあれば、hiがhのn個のサブシステムの一つに作用するHamiltonianであるような
完全な系の小さなサブセットのエネルギー寄与の理解から組み立てる必要がある場合もある。
また、素粒子を扱う場合、系がfermionかbosonかも注意する必要がある。次に、
Hamiltonianをエンコードし、量子コンピュータが理解できる用語に変換する必要がある。多くの場合、
これらのHamiltonianは素粒子またはスピン系で構成される。fermionやbosonをシミュレートする場合は、
Jordan-WignerやBravyi-Kitaevのようなエンコード変換を選択する必要がある。これらの変換は
元のコンポーネント、つまりfermionまたは
bosonで書かれたHamiltonianの定義を、量子コンピュータのgateに簡単に変換できるPauli演算子に変換する方法を教えてくれる。例えば、Jordan-Wigner
変換はfermion演算子からPauli演算子へのマッピングを定義する。すでに
非常に一般的なスピン1/2系を扱っている場合は、正規化係数の問題を除いて
エンコードスキームを使う必要はない。望むHamiltonianを量子コンピュータのgate setにエンコードしたら、
次の重要なステップは、シミュレーションを開始する適切な初期量子状態を決定することだ。
この状態は理想的には、研究対象の系の何らかの物理的な意味や
構成を反映すべきだ。例えば、分子の基底状態エネルギーの探索に興味がある場合、
Hartree-Fock近似や、真の基底状態と有意な重なりを持つ他の容易に準備できる状態から始めるかもしれない。
初期基底状態の選択は、変分アルゴリズムの収束だけでなく、
VQE（変分量子固有値ソルバー）の精度と効率にも影響する。また
量子位相推定における時間発展やサンプリングにも影響する。本質的に、初期状態は
計算の出発点として機能し、モデル化している量子系に関する有用な観測量を
引き出すための舞台を設定する。ciが計算基底状態でaiが係数である任意のn qubit状態の準備は
各状態のそれぞれの係数と正規化条件 2のn乗マイナス1は、一般的に次のようにアプローチできる。
演算子oで状態を初期化することで。開始状態は全ゼロの標準基底状態で、しばしばこのように書かれる。
簡略化のために。一般的に、これには指数関数的な数のCノット gate が必要だ。多くの場合、
システムの特定の初期状態に関心があり、その準備は適切な量の
リソースで実装できる。例えば、qubit が互いにエンタングルしていない積状態は、単一
qubit 演算のみを必要とする。さて、trotterization について話す機会がまだなかったが、
もうすでに知っている人もいるだろう。本質的に、trotterization は行列指数演算を計算する手法で、
非可換演算子の指数的な性質を扱うために近似を使う。HAのような2つの演算子が
HBと非可換の場合、巧妙なトリックを使う必要があり、対応する指数関数を交互に適用する。
e の iHA乗 と e の iHB乗 を、n回
繰り返す。交互の時間発展演算子が適用される。ここでは証明は省略するが、
説明欄にこの命題のシンプルな証明へのリンクを載せる。肝心なのはこれだ。時間発展は
マッピングの重要な部分でもある。Trotterization は連続的な相互作用を、量子コンピュータで
実装できる離散的なステップに分解する。trotterized circuit を生成した後、マッピング
ステップがついに完了する。次は circuit の最適化に移れる。
そのために、以下を達成する必要がある。circuit 内の仮想 qubit を
ハードウェア上の物理的なものにマッピングする qubit レイアウトが必要だ。これが必要なのは、ハードウェアが特定のトポロジーを持つ
場合があり、物理 qubit の直接の相互作用が制限されるからだ。一方、
quantum circuit の実装では、どの qubit も他のどの qubit とも相互作用できると仮定することが多い。次に、接続されていない qubit 間の相互作用を経路制御するために
スワップ gate を必要に応じて挿入する必要がある。circuit 内の
gate を、命令セットアーキテクチャ（ISA）の命令に変換する必要がある。
その命令はハードウェア上で直接実行できる。次に circuit の最適化を行い、
circuit の深さと gate 数を最小化する。このステップは仮想 circuit 上でも実行できる。qubit が
まだデバイストポロジーにマッピングされていない circuit でも。ただし、これの大部分は
Qiskit が自動的に行ってくれることを覚えておこう。次のセクションで具体的にどうなるか見ていく。最適化ステップの後、primitive を使って
circuit を実行する準備が整う。ほとんどのシミュレーション実験では、時間とともに変化する
システムの特定の性質の変化を理解することに関心がある。だから、estimator primitive を使うことになるだろう。それが
特定の性質に対応する観測量の期待値を測定できるからだ。次に、
estimator の最良のオプションを設定する。これにより、エラー抑制とエラー緩和の技術を追加できる。最後に
実験を実行する。最後のステップは、全データのポスト処理だ。これにより、測定された期待値、またはサンプラーを使っている場合は
計算基底でのサンプル確率分布が抽出される。必要なのが
関心のある観測量の期待値だけなら、これらは estimator
primitive から直接、生の値とエラー緩和された値の両方で取得できる。多くの場合、測定された期待値は
量子計算を必要とせず、古典的なコンピュータで計算できる
他の関心量の計算に使われる。
では、IBMが数年前に発表した非常に影響力のある論文の実際の例を見ていく。
その論文は「フォールトトレランス前の量子コンピューティングのユーティリティの証拠」というものだ。この論文は親しみを込めて
ユーティリティ論文と略称で呼ばれ、発表直後から量子コンピューティングの分野で非常に影響力のある論文となった。
この論文の全体的な主張は、ノイズのある量子コンピュータが正確な結果、つまり期待値を
127個の qubit と2,880個の gate を使って、ブルートフォース計算
——ハードウェアで実行された quantum circuit の完全シミュレーション——の能力を超えて生成したというものだ。この研究は
量子コンピュータを使って、量子シミュレーションの他の近似古典的手法との結果を検証・比較できることを示したことでも重要だった。
テンソルネットワークアルゴリズムのような手法で、事前に解が分かっていない場合でも。また非常に面白いのは、
IBM量子システムをクラウドで使う他の人たちが
Qiskit を使って、これらの結果を自分で再現・検証できることだ。
その方法を説明しよう。この例では、この問題を量子デバイスが理解できる入力に
マッピングするステップについて、もう少し具体的に説明する。この場合、
格子上の磁気双極子スピンのシステムの全磁化のダイナミクスを
外部磁場下でシミュレートする。このシステムは横磁場を持つイジングモデルで記述できる。
これをパラメータ化された quantum circuit でモデル化し、パラメータはスピン間の
またはZ相互作用の調整可能な値と磁場Xの強さに対応する。
このシリーズは「実践的な量子コンピューティング」と呼ばれている。だから、この実験で
結果を可能な限り良くするための手順についても議論する。次に、
不良 qubit、つまり低い gate 忠実度や非コヒーレンス時間を持つ qubit を取り除く方法を議論する。これらは実験結果に大きく影響する可能性がある。
これらの不良 qubit は、不適切な事前キャリブレーション
や、qubit と相互作用する二準位系によって生じる可能性がある。ハードウェアのネイティブトポロジーからいくつかの qubit を取り除くことは、
結果として得られるトポロジーで記述された格子上のシステムを考慮することに対応する。また、
trotterization によるシステムの時間発展を実装するパラメータ化された quantum circuit の作成についても議論する。
この目的のために、エンタングリング層を特定することが重要だ。これは後で使用する主な
エラー緩和技術の重要な部分だ。この時点で、視聴者の皆さんに知っておいてほしいのは、
以下にリンクされているチュートリアルとIBM
quantum learningプラットフォームで、これから説明することを全て追いかけられるということだ。このチュートリアルで気づくのは、一連のヘルパー関数が作成されていることだ。
後で使えるようにノートブックの早い段階でいくつかの関数を定義しておく。これらについて
今話しておきたい。公式あるいは正式なプロセスの一部だからではなく、実験者がよくやることだからだ
実際の現場でこういった実験を実行する際にね。また、問題をさらに
細かく分解する方法も見えてくる。ノートブックで定義する関数は次の通りだ。Remove cubit couplings。
Define cubit couplings。Construct the layer couplings。Construct entangling layers。そして最後に、define trotterized
circuit。次は、layer couplingsについて話そう。シミュレーション中にqubitが
隣のqubitとどう相互作用するかを定義するものだ。量子デバイスはheavy hexagonal
layoutと呼ばれるものを使っている。qubitを接続するための特殊なパターンだ。このlayoutでは、edgeと呼ばれる接続を3つの
別々のセットにグループ化できる。同じセット内の2つの接続がqubitを共有しないようにだ。これは
実際の量子コンピュータでは、同じqubitが関わる2 qubit gateを同時に実行できないから重要なんだ。
各qubitは一度に1つのgateにしか関与できない。
すべての接続を3つのlayerに分けることで、デバイス全体に2 qubit gateを3
ラウンドで適用できる。各layerで1つのgateにしか使われないqubitはない。これらの
gateはIsingモデルのZZ相互作用を実装していて、シミュレーションの各ステップ、つまり
trotterステップごとに繰り返される。twirlingはデバイスのノイズを修正して、単純なノイズモデルでも
精度が高くなるようにする。これにより、ノイズモデルを正確に学習して得られた
情報をエラー軽減技術に活用することも可能になる。
次に、使用可能な物理qubitのリストから問題のあるqubitを除外しなければならない。
さっきも言ったように、qubitが問題になる理由はいろいろある。単純に
キャリブレーションが悪い場合もある。再キャリブレーションするだけで解決できる単純なミスだ。
もう少し複雑な場合もあって、TLSと呼ばれるもの、つまり2準位界面
欠陥に関係していることがある。qubitパラメータの揺らぎや緩和を引き起こす。これは
システム全体を少し温めてから冷却することで解決できる。ただしそれには時間がかかるし、
クラウド越しにはできない。だから今は、可能な物理
qubitのリストから除外するのが一番簡単だ。どのqubitが期待通りに動作していないかはIBM Quantum Platformから簡単に確認できる。
プラットフォーム上でqubitの特性をプロットするか、CSVとしてダウンロードできる。除外したい
qubitのリストを作成して、デバイス上の全物理qubitのリストから削除するだけだ。
よし。では、trotterized circuitを生成するマッピングステップを続けよう。先ほど示したように、
trotterizationは時間発展を一連のステップに離散化する。何ステップにするかを決める必要がある。
ここでは6を選ぶ。ただし一般的な戦略は、trotterエラーと呼ばれるものとのバランスをとることだ。
アルゴリズム的な近似誤差とデコヒーレンスから生じる誤差のバランスだ。trotterステップを増やすと近似
誤差は減るが、より深い量子circuitが必要になり、デコヒーレンスノイズが増える。thetaパラメータを使って
circuitを定義する。thetaは外部磁場の強さ、layer couplings、
ステップ数とqubit数、そしてもちろんデバイスのbackendだ。
外部磁場の強さによってシステムの磁化が変わるため、様々な磁場強度値で
シミュレーションを実行するのは興味深い。それらはcircuit内のRXの
回転の異なる角度に変換される。circuitの生成が終わったら、最適化に移ろう。
最初のステップはpass managerの定義だ。Qiskit SDKの文脈では、transpilationとは
入力circuitを量子デバイスで実行可能な形に変換するプロセスのことだ。
transpilationは通常、transpiler passesと呼ばれる一連のステップで行われる。pass managerは
transpiler passesのリストを保持し、circuitに対して実行できるオブジェクトだ。pass managerオブジェクトをtranspiler passesのリストで初期化して
pass managerを作成する。最終的に、pass managerは
ISA circuit、つまりbackendの命令セットアーキテクチャで記述されたcircuitを生成する。
backendにネイティブなcircuitとgateを記述するが、実行に必要なタイミング情報が欠けている。
これでcircuitを実行する準備ができた。Qiskitパターンのステップ3だ。先ほど述べた通り、
この実験ではestimatorをプリミティブとして使う。システムの全
磁化を測定したいし、observablesの期待値を推定することがestimatorの
設計目的だからだ。このステップではエラー軽減のオプションを指定することも重要だ。最良の結果を得るためにzero noise
extrapolationを使う。特にチュートリアルでは、外挿モデルを評価するために2つ以上の
noise factor値を指定し、
amplificationオプションとしてprobabilistic error amplificationを指定しているのがわかる。さて、probabilistic
error amplificationつまりPAは、他のオプションと比べてはるかにスケールが
優れているため、ここではエラー軽減技術として選ばれた。100 qubit以上のレベルで作業する際はそれが重要だ。
最後に実験を実行する。完了まで少し時間がかかるが、今はチュートリアルから
キューに入れて保存したデータを参照しよう。メタデータを調べ、layered gatesと
mitigated layersに特に注目する。生データから大量のエラーを除去するのにそれらを使うからだ。最終結果を
プロットする準備がほぼできた。ただその前に、zero
noise extrapolationつまりZNEが正確に何を意味するかについて、ここで少し補足しよう。以前のエピソードで簡単に触れたが、復習すると、zero noise extrapolation
はcircuit実行中の未知のノイズの影響を除去するエラー軽減技術で、
既知の方法でスケールできる。期待値がノイズと既知の関数によってスケールすると仮定する。ここに示したもので、
lambdaパラメータがノイズ強度を指定し、増幅できる。ZNEは次のステップで実装できる。
まず、いくつかのノイズ係数に対してcircuitのノイズを増幅する。ラムダ1、ラムダ2、
ラムダ3、以下同様だ。ノイズ増幅された全てのcircuitを実行して、
期待値a(ラムダ1)、a(ラムダ2)などを測定する。そしてゼロノイズの
極限、期待値a(0)へと外挿する。
Z&の実装を成功させる上での主な課題は、期待値におけるノイズの正確なモデルを持つことと、
既知の方法でノイズを増幅することだ。
Z&のエラー増幅の実装方法は3つある。キャリブレーションによるパルス持続時間のスケーリング、
恒等サイクルでのgateの繰り返し、そしてpyチャンネルのサンプリングによるノイズ付加だ。
後者をPAと呼ぶ。確率的エラー増幅がここでの最良の選択だ。パルスの引き伸ばしは非常に
計算コストが高いからだ。gateのfoldingはノイズバイアスを保持する理論的保証に欠ける。だがPAは
ネイティブなノイズ係数で実行可能な任意のcircuitに適用できるが、ノイズモデルの学習が必要だ。PAは
確率的エラーキャンセルと同じ層ベースのノイズモデルを仮定している。
ただし、circuitのノイズに対して指数的にスケールするサンプリングオーバーヘッドを回避できる。ノイズモデルを学習するには、
まずcircuit内の2 qubit演算のユニークな層を特定しなければならない。
各層について、2 qubit gateをpoly twirl処理して、ノイズがdampingノイズモデルで適切に記述されることを保証する。
様々な深さで層の恒等ペアを繰り返し、最後に各ノイズチャンネルのfidelityまたはエラーをフィットする。そして
もちろん、この手法をある程度理解しておくことは勧めるが、Qiskitで手作業でやるより
チュートリアルに示されているようにずっとシンプルだ。さて最後に、プロットされたデータを見てみよう。点線の
灰色の線は、近似誤差を持つ近似古典的手法で得られた正確な結果を示している。
近似誤差は低い閾値に収束している。見ての通り、最初に選んだ異なるノイズ係数の生データは
この点線からかなり離れている。青い実線はZ&処理を考慮したデータを示していて、
一目で正確な結果にずっと近いことがわかる。
まとめると、ノイズのある値は正確な値から大きく外れている。
緩和された値は正確な値に近く、PEAベースの緩和技術の有用性を示している。
これでこのエピソードは実質的に終わりだ。学んだことを簡単にまとめると、量子シミュレーションは
短中期的に最も有望なアプリケーション分野の一つだ。
製薬から高エネルギー物理学まで幅広い応用がある。
材料科学などにも及ぶ。IBMが2023年に発表したutility論文は
科学的発見のために量子コンピュータを活用する道筋を示した。そして我々は
その論文に関連するチュートリアルを深く掘り下げて進めた。シミュレーション問題を最初から最後まで
解き進めるステップは比較的わかりやすい、特に慣れてしまえばね。私の希望は
これからこの動画とチュートリアルを、今後のさらに多くのシミュレーション問題のガイドとして活用してほしいということだ。
ご視聴ありがとう、またQuantum Computing in Practiceでお会いしよう。